we know that women make less money than  men really women are the victims of rape  and sexual violence at the hands of men  much more often okay than the other way  around but no actually men are raped  more often when you include the prison  population and that does matter because  men are convicted much more harshly for  the exact same crimes as women as far as  the 77 cents on the dollar if you  believe that I think you really should  do a little bit more research because  all that does is compare the median  income from women in the workforce to  the median income of men in the  workforce it doesn't take into account  hours worked it doesn't take you into  account risk of Labor doesn't take into  account travel time away from family  when you account for all of those facets  women actually in most studies make a  little bit more than men but exactly the  same you could drop the mic Crowder you  just killed it well you said you were  short for time